One of the most used implicit intents
in Android is the share intent.
(laughs) It's awesome.
It's a great way to waste time
for both you and your friends.
(cell phone rings)
- (chuckles)
- (director) Dan!
You can leverage your favorite apps
to share photos, texts,
videos and general links.
And the best part is you don't have
to even know what the user's
favorite apps are.
Just tell Android what data you want
to share and it shows your users
a list of apps that will share it,
apps that may not have existed
when you app was written.
To make it even easier to share,
Android 4.0 added
the share action provider
and we have it for previous releases
of Android as part of a support library.
It operates using the action send intent.
If we use Raytoe's
glorious envelope metaphor,
it would be addressed to anyone
who could perform action send.
The data descend would be
included with it as extras,
either as text,
or URI to the binary data.
And the MIME type would indicate
what the URI points to.
Here's what the share action provider
will bring to our app:
the glorious wire frame.
There will be an additional icon
in the action bar, which will
drop down a menu
when clicked to reveal
potential share actions.
Another icon will be added
to the right of this one
that contains the last
application shared to.
Add a ShareActionProvider
to the fragment within DetailActivity.
It will share weather
in the following format.
Yes, it's just the string we passed
into the view, plus #SunshineApp.